il ya des beaux spécimens
valérie beaudouin hausse pour la
première fois depuis des mois
dépoussiérer la terrasse de son
restaurant au bord de la loire à orléans
une façon de s'occuper l'esprit en
attendant le discours du premier
ministre edouard philippe
après le long confinement et le choc de
la fermeture
valérie et patrice un couple de maître
restaurateur ose enfin espérer les
restaurants bars et cafés pourront
ouvrir un soulagement qui suscite une
réaction mitigée avec un masque on va
passer avoir déjà fin l'accueil va pas
reconnaître forcément les gens
on sait pas s'il sourit ou pas le
serveur qui il est
cette aire aimable enfin voila ca veut
côté masque
évidemment c'est pas forcément très
sympa mais déjà mais où rouvre donc je
suis bien un retour à l'activité pour
tout un secteur de l'économie française
alors que le gouvernement annonce une
augmentation vertigineuse du taux de
chômage
il n'y a pas eu en france plus de
demandeurs d'emploi depuis 1996 près de
13 millions de français sont à la
recherche d'un boulot c'est en grande
partie pour eux pour combattre ce
nouveau fléau que le gouvernement va de
l'avant avec la deuxième phase du
déconfinement à partir du 2 juin
toutes les écoles les parcs et jardins
et les plages vont ouvrir la france doit
retrouver un certain air de normalité la
liberté enfin va redevenir la règle et
l'interdiction constituera l'exception
cette liberté renouveler c'est aussi
celle de se déplacer si les frontières
restent fermés les français pourront
désormais voyager dans tout le pays sans
égard à la distance parcourue
le château de chambord un repaire de
chasse extravagant construit par le roi
françois 1er a sans doute plus que
jamais ses allures d'antan l'absence de
visiteurs laisse tout loisir d'apprécier
le décor bucolique qui lui sert de cadre
un plaisir certes mais qui ne peut plus
durer
je suis quand même un peu inquiet pour
la saison je pense que les français vont
vouloir retrouver leur patrimoine et
leur pays et puis tu as une pompe a
tellement sortir qu'il faudra qu'on
serre les boulons et que on se prépare
quand même à nous trois années qui
seront moins faciles de cavan
avant on sent partout nostalgie pour
cette époque pas si lointaine qui
aujourd'hui semble appartenir à
l'histoire tout autant que ses pierres
érigées à une toute autre époque
et si marie-eve bédard radio-canada en
valent 2